entanglement kuantum memungkinkan partikel-partikel terhubung terlepas dari jarak di antara mereka ini begitu kontra-intuitif
sehingga bahkan Einstein pun tidak percaya itu benar dalam episode hari ini dari Qiskit in the classroom kita akan membahas bagaimana teorema Bell
membuktikan Einstein
salah selamat datang di Qiskit in the classroom dalam seri ini kita akan menggunakan Qiskit untuk menjelajahi beberapa konsep fundamental yang umumnya
dibahas dalam kursus terkait Quantum Computing setiap video juga akan disertai modul interaktif
yang ditautkan di deskripsi di bawah jadi pastikan kamu lihat itu dalam video quantum coins kita membahas bagaimana mengukur
superposisi kuantum adalah proses yang secara inheren probabilistik seperti melempar koin dalam beberapa hal tapi bagaimana kita tahu
ini bisa jadi partikel kuantum secara diam-diam menyembunyikan hasil yang sudah ditentukan sebelumnya dari pengukuran tapi kita entah bagaimana gagal
menangkap informasi ini dalam teori kita pada awal-awal mekanika kuantum pertanyaan ini adalah subjek
perdebatan sengit dengan dua faksi utama di satu kubu adalah Einstein yang percaya bahwa mekanika kuantum tidak lengkap
artinya bahwa ada variabel-variabel yang hilang yang diperlukan untuk mendeskripsikan sistem sepenuhnya Einstein berpikir bahwa
apa yang disebut variabel tersembunyi ini kalau ditemukan akan menyelesaikan beberapa aspek mekanika kuantum yang tampaknya paradoksal dan probabilistik
di kubu lain adalah Max Born Born berpendapat
bahwa deskripsi probabilistik yang diberikan oleh mekanika kuantum adalah semua yang ditentukan oleh alam dengan kata lain
bukan hanya kita yang tidak tahu state partikel sebelum mengukurnya tapi partikel itu tidak memiliki state yang pasti
sebelum diukur selama beberapa dekade banyak yang mengira ketidaksepakatan ini adalah pertanyaan filosofis yang mungkin tidak akan pernah
terselesaikan bagaimanapun juga untuk mempelajari sesuatu tentang sistem kita perlu mengukurnya bagaimana kita bisa mempelajari
apa pun tentang sifat state sebelum pengukurannya kemudian pada tahun 1964 fisikawan
John Bell menemukan caranya dalam makalahnya Bell memeriksa korelasi statistik antara pengukuran dari sepasang
partikel yang saling terjerat kalau sebelum pengukuran state dari partikel-partikel tersebut ditentukan oleh beberapa variabel tersembunyi yang tidak diketahui
maka Bell menemukan bahwa korelasi mereka memiliki batas atas di sisi lain ketika dia menghitung
korelasi yang diprediksi oleh mekanika kuantum dia menemukan bahwa mereka melanggar batas ini jadi dia telah menemukan cara untuk sekali
dan untuk selamanya membedakan antara pandangan Einstein dan Born yang tersisa hanyalah untuk benar-benar secara eksperimental
menguji korelasi ini dengan partikel nyata untuk melihat apakah mereka mematuhi statistik variabel tersembunyi atau mereka
melanggar aturan tersebut pengujian ini dilakukan dengan presisi dan kecanggihan yang semakin meningkat
dari waktu ke waktu dan mereka adalah beberapa eksperimen paling signifikan dari fisika modern mereka begitu revolusioner sehingga
mereka mengantarkan tiga fisikawan meraih Nobel Prize pada tahun 2022 tapi zaman sekarang siapa pun bisa melakukan
uji Bell yang kita butuhkan hanyalah sedikit pengetahuan tentang Qiskit dan akses ke komputer kuantum IBM dalam video ini aku akan
memandu kamu melalui logika pertidaksamaan Bell kemudian aku akan menunjukkan bagaimana kita bisa menguji prediksi Bell pada komputer kuantum
IBM pertidaksamaan Bell melibatkan beberapa pengukuran berbeda dan lapisan logika dan itu bisa agak
rumit untuk diikuti tapi kita akan membahasnya langkah demi langkah dan pada akhirnya itu akan sepadan kita akan segera menunjukkan
bahwa entanglement itu nyata dan Einstein salah itu bukan sesuatu yang banyak orang bisa katakan pernah mereka lakukan jadi ini
yang diusulkan Bell katakanlah kamu punya cara untuk menghasilkan banyak salinan dari sepasang partikel yang saling terjerat secara fisik
pasangan-pasangan ini bisa dihasilkan melalui proses peluruhan di mana satu partikel meluruh menjadi dua kalau kamu menonton video tentang
eksperimen Stern-Gerlach kamu tahu bahwa partikel bisa memiliki momentum sudut intrinsik yang disebut
spin katakanlah satu partikel spin nol meluruh menjadi dua partikel
spin 1/2 kemudian masing-masing partikel spin 1/2 bisa diukur memiliki spin plus setengah atau minus
setengah juga disebut spin up atau spin down tapi karena mereka meluruh dari partikel spin nol maka keduanya harus bergabung untuk
memiliki total spin nol juga jadi kalau satu diukur menjadi up yang lain harus menjadi
down dan sebaliknya partikel-partikel ini membentuk pasangan yang saling terjerat yang terlihat seperti ini
jadi kalau satu diukur menjadi up yang lain adalah down dan sebaliknya katakanlah partikel satu terbang ke kiri atau
arah minus X di mana peneliti yang akan kita sebut Lucas mengukur spin-nya
kemudian partikel dua juga terbang ke kanan
di mana peneliti lain Rihanna bisa mengukur spin tersebut Lucas dan Rihanna bisa secara independen
memutar perangkat pengukuran mereka untuk memilih mengukur spin dari partikel masing-masing sepanjang arah mana pun
tegak lurus terhadap arah gerak partikel kalau kita mengirimkan banyak salinan state yang saling terjerat kepada Lucas
dan Rihanna mereka bisa mengumpulkan statistik pengukuran kalau mereka selalu mengukur sepanjang sumbu yang sama statistik ini tidak akan
terlalu menarik setiap kali satu mengukur spin up yang lain mengukur spin down dan setiap kali satu mengukur
spin maju yang lain mengukur spin mundur dan seterusnya tapi kalau dua peneliti mengukur sepanjang sumbu berbeda kita mungkin menemukan
sesuatu yang lebih menarik mari kita beri Lucas dan Rihanna tiga sumbu untuk
diukur kita akan sebut sumbu-sumbu ini a b dan c dan masing-masing dipisahkan oleh
120° pertanyaan yang akan kita tanyakan dengan eksperimen ini adalah kalau Lucas dan Rihanna bebas mengukur sepanjang salah satu dari tiga
sumbu seberapa sering keduanya akan mendapatkan tanda yang sama jelas kalau Lucas dan Rihanna kebetulan mengukur sepanjang sumbu yang sama
katakanlah sumbu a mereka tidak pernah bisa mendapatkan tanda yang sama karena partikel-partikel harus bergabung memiliki spin nol tapi ketika mereka memilih
sumbu yang berbeda bagaimana pengukuran mereka akan berkorelasi kalau ada menurut Einstein deskripsi mekanika kuantum
ini dari state partikel tidak lengkap dia berpikir harus ada variabel tersembunyi yang
menentukan sebelumnya hasil dari semua kemungkinan pengukuran spin karena tanpa itu partikel yang saling terjerat harus
entah bagaimana mengkomunikasikan hasil pengukuran mereka satu sama lain secara instan jika satu diukur menjadi
up jauh di sini yang lain harus seketika tahu untuk menjadi down di
sini variabel tersembunyi ini bisa berupa kumpulan instruksi yang rumit untuk hasil eksperimen tapi intinya adalah
bahwa state spin dari masing-masing partikel secara terpisah sudah ditentukan sehingga tidak diperlukan komunikasi
WEBVTT
secara eksperimental itu berarti pengukuran yang dilakukan Lucas tidak akan berpengaruh pada partikel Rihanna dan sebaliknya
ini bisa memberikan beberapa batasan pada seberapa berkorelasi dua pengukuran tersebut menurut Born meskipun state
psi adalah semua yang bisa dikatakan tentang sepasang partikel sebelum pengukuran jadi pengukuran satu partikel
mempengaruhi hasil pengukuran yang lain ini mungkin memiliki implikasi berbeda untuk korelasi antara pengukuran mari kita lihat bagaimana masing-masing
teori mempengaruhi korelasi ini dalam perlakuan variabel tersembunyi ada set instruksi rahasia sebelum
pengukuran yang sudah menentukan apa yang akan diukur Lucas sepanjang masing-masing dari tiga sumbu misalnya
instruksi ini bisa positif kalau Lucas mengukur sepanjang sumbu a
positif kalau dia mengukur sepanjang B dan negatif kalau dia mengukur sepanjang c kita bisa
menulis ini sebagai plus a plus b dan minus C kemudian partikel Rihanna
perlu memiliki variabel minus a minus B dan plus C untuk memastikan bahwa total
spin sepanjang arah tunggal mana pun adalah nol
ada delapan set instruksi yang mungkin yang memenuhi kendala spin nol ini jadi setiap kali sepasang partikel baru
dikirimkan ke Lucas dan Rihanna ini bisa mengandung salah satu dari delapan set instruksi ini jadi sekarang kita ingin
mencari tahu dengan asumsi partikel mengandung salah satu set instruksi rahasia yang diberikan dalam tabel dan
dengan asumsi Lucas dan Rihanna masing-masing secara independen memilih sumbu mana di antara tiga sumbu yang akan diukur apa
probabilitas bahwa keduanya mengukur tanda yang sama jika instruksinya adalah yang diberikan dalam baris 1 atau
8 maka jelas probabilitas ini adalah nol karena dua partikel akan memiliki tanda yang berlawanan terlepas dari sumbu
pengukuran mereka tapi bagaimana dengan instruksi dalam baris dua mereka akan mengukur tanda yang sama kalau
Rihanna mengukur sepanjang c dan Lucas mengukur sepanjang a atau b atau kalau Lucas
mengukur sepanjang c dan Rihanna mengukur sepanjang A atau B jadi itu empat dari sembilan
kombinasi pengukuran yang mungkin yang akan memberi Lucas dan Rihanna tanda yang sama kalau kita melakukan ini untuk
setiap set instruksi kamu akan melihat bahwa baris 3 sampai 7 juga memberikan probabilitas 4/9 ini berarti bahwa kalau
Einstein benar dan variabel tersembunyi seperti ini menentukan hasil pengukuran sebelumnya tidak ada cara bagi Lucas
dan Rihanna untuk pernah mengukur tanda yang sama dengan probabilitas lebih besar dari 4/9 ini adalah pertidaksamaan Bell P kurang dari
atau sama dengan 4/9 dan seperti yang akan kita tunjukkan partikel yang saling terjerat melanggar ini jadi untuk
melihat apa yang diprediksi mekanika kuantum katakanlah Lucas mengukur sepanjang a dua hal bisa terjadi entah dia mengukur spin up sehingga
Rihanna akan mengukur spin down sepanjang a atau dia mengukur spin down dan Rihanna akan mengukur spin up sepanjang a tapi kita
ingin probabilitas bahwa Rihanna mengukur tanda yang sama dengan Lucas sepanjang sumbu mana pun yang dia pilih bukan hanya a kalau
dia mengukur sepanjang B atau C ini menjadi sedikit rumit ternyata bahwa
kalau kamu tahu apa yang akan diukur Rihanna dengan kepastian 100% sepanjang satu arah maka kamu bisa menghitung probabilitas
bahwa dia akan mengukur up atau down sepanjang sumbu lain mana pun dengan sedikit geometri
kalau state kamu selalu mengukur spin up sepanjang satu sumbu maka probabilitas mengukur spin up sepanjang sumbu yang berbeda
akan sama dengan kuadrat dari cosinus dari setengah sudut antara dua sumbu itu agak rumit tapi
aku akan menunjukkan maksudku kalau Lucas mengukur spin up sepanjang a kita tahu dengan kepastian 100% Rihanna akan mengukur
spin down kalau dia mengukur a jadi kita bisa merepresentasikan itu dengan vektor seperti
ini dalam kasus ini sudut antara vektor ini dan dua sumbu pengukuran lainnya B dan C keduanya
60° jadi setengah dari itu adalah 30° dan kosinus dari
30 ditampilkan di sini kuadrat kosinus
30° sama dengan 3/4 sekarang bagaimana kalau Lucas mengukur spin down
sepanjang a kita tahu Rihanna akan mengukur spin up sepanjang a jadi kita bisa menggambar vektor lain di sini sekarang
vektor yang merepresentasikan pengetahuan ini berjarak 120° dari masing-masing dua sumbu lainnya B
dan C jadi kita bisa melakukan trik geometri yang sama tapi kali ini kita akan mendapatkan kosinus dari
60° jadi kuadrat kosinus dari
60° sama dengan 1/4 karena Lucas sama-sama mungkin untuk
mengukur spin up dan spin down sepanjang a kita perlu merata-ratakan dua probabilitas Rihanna ini kita mendapatkan probabilitas akhir
bahwa Rihanna akan mengukur tanda yang sama dengan Lucas sebesar 1/2 jadi P
sama dengan 1/2 adalah lebih besar dari 4/9 jadi pertidaksamaan Bell dilanggar
itu berarti bahwa selama aturan mekanika kuantum berlaku variabel tersembunyi tidak mungkin sekarang kita bisa menggunakan Qiskit dan
komputer kuantum IBM untuk menguji pertidaksamaan Bell dengan pengukuran kuantum nyata kita bisa memetakan spin up dan
spin down dari partikel Lucas dan Rihanna ke state nol dan satu dari qubit dalam komputer kuantum kita akan
mengambil dua qubit satu untuk mewakili partikel Lucas dan satu untuk Rihanna dan menjerat mereka dengan quantum circuit ini
jadi dua qubit direpresentasikan oleh dua kabel q0 dan q1 dan kombinasi
dari X Hadamard dan CNOT gate ini akan membuat state yang sama yang saling terjerat yang kita miliki antara partikel Lucas dan Rihanna sekarang kita
perlu mengukur setiap qubit kita akan mengatur pengukuran Lucas sepanjang a yang akan kita katakan adalah sumbu Z kemudian pengukuran Rihanna
bisa sepanjang a b atau c jadi kita akan membutuhkan tiga circuit terpisah untuk masing-masing dari tiga kasus ini tapi dalam
video ini kita hanya akan melakukan satu kamu bisa pergi ke modul yang ditautkan di deskripsi untuk keseluruhannya kalau Rihanna mengukur sepanjang
B maka circuit kita terlihat seperti ini di mana ry adalah rotasi 120 derajat untuk mengubah
sumbu pengukuran Rihanna kita bisa menggunakan Qiskit primitive sampler untuk menjalankan eksperimen ini berkali-kali dan mengumpulkan
statistik dari pengukuran yang dihasilkan dua kolom 0 0 dan 1 1 mewakili waktu ketika Lucas dan
Rihanna mengukur tanda yang sama yang itulah yang kita cari jadi probabilitas mengukur kedua partikel memiliki
tanda yang sama hampir mendekati 1/2 ini melanggar pertidaksamaan Bell ini berarti
WEBVTT
bahwa dua partikel tersebut saling terjerat masing-masing tampaknya secara instan mengetahui hasil dari
pengukuran yang lain masih ada beberapa ketidaksepakatan tentang bagaimana tepatnya menginterpretasikan
entanglement ini dan apa yang terjadi ketika kamu mengukur state yang saling terjerat tapi pertanyaan-pertanyaan ini lebih bersifat filosofis
teorinya cukup tidak bisa disangkal pada titik ini entanglement pasti nyata dan kita tahu ini berkat Bell
pertidaksamaannya dan banyak fisikawan yang telah melakukan eksperimen untuk mengujinya kalau kamu ingin termasuk di antara para
fisikawan tersebut dan melakukan uji Bell sendiri dengan komputer kuantum pastikan kamu kunjungi modul pertidaksamaan Bell
yang ditautkan di deskripsi terima kasih sudah menonton dan sampai jumpa lain kali